Too much.
Hello world, it's a Raj and
welcome to this live stream. Uh,
in this live stream I'm
going to be talking about a
node dot js and we're going
to be using machine learning for that.
Uh,
so the code is going to show
up behind me when I move it.
So it's going to show up.
Just setting up some lives,
a lot of things right now it looks like
the code is not behind. There we go. Okay,
cool. Cool, cool, cool. Cool. All right,
so, okay, I'm so excited to be here.
Thank you guys for coming. Uh, so
we have a lot to talk about. Today.
We are going to build a node dot js app
from scratch and this app is going to be
able to translate to in real
time. So check this out.
Here's the translation demo.
Okay, let me make this a little
bigger. So this is in real time.
This is what's happening.
Okay. I can say, how are you?
And it's going to translate
it in real time into French.
So English to French
translation in the browser.
Immediately I can say hello world.
It's Saroj. And then, uh,
it's going to say, you know,
whatever it needs to say.
Okay?
So that's the demo that we
are going to build today. Uh,
this person is saying my left ear is
highly educated. Well, guess what?
Your right ear is going to be as well
because there's no audio in the left ear.
Okay? We're, we're gonna fix that. We're
going to fix that for you. Okay? So
yeah,
his day on, we're going to fix
that for you. In the meantime,
let's get right into this. Okay? So, ah,
what I want to do is just say five names
and then I'm going to start a coding
this. Okay. So, uh, I'm unprepared, uh,
silly Tian and Martin and Depok and uh,
okay.
Russia. Okay. And then the
question, I only see one question.
Have you ever loved anybody? Yes. It's
called my community. It's called you guys.
So that's why I do this thing.
Okay. So let's make everything big.
And now we're going to look at this.
So I'm going to talk a little bit
about what no job, no dot js is.
And then we're going to talk about how
machine translation works using sequence
to sequence models. And then we're going
to code this thing out in Java script.
Okay?
Okay.
All right. So let's, let's get
right into this. So No. Dot js.
So javascript was initially
invented just for,
just for in the browser scripting.
It wasn't made to create stand
alone applications, right?
So you wouldn't build a model that
allows for requests to be coming in,
uh,
in javascript.
And javascript wasn't made initially to
handle a bunch of concurrent requests,
you know, like for posts, requests
for, for, for data, et Cetera.
But the developers of node
dot. Js said, you know what,
let's create a javascript
runtime environment.
That's an entire environment that you
can use javascript to create stand alone
web apps. And since then it's kind of
exploded in popularity. Look, no. Dot.
JS is not a new technology. It's a,
it's, it's, it's a relatively, um,
you know, in, in, in programming
terms, it's an older technology.
It's about five years or more
older, but it's a very, um,
it's a very good technology
and we can use it.
We can combine it with machine
learning for some amazing results.
So if we look at the analogy of Java,
so most of us are familiar with Java
because computer science one oh one class
is a teach Java generally. And
if you're not, that's okay. Uh,
but basically what I'm trying to show is
the analogy of what a node runs on and
it runs on what's called
The v eight engine.
And Va engine was created for c plus
plus specifically, but it, but yeah,
you can use it with javascript now.
And what it does is you type in javascript
in the browser and it compiles it
down to very fast machine code that's
readable by your machine. Okay.
So no longer is it? No
longer is javascript just
constrained to the browser.
You can use it for all sorts of things.
Okay.
Nice audio for you. Fix the audio. All
right, well it's fine now. Okay. So, uh,
the other thing about
node dot js is so on.
If we look at the official
node dot js website,
let's look at the official node
dot. Js website or write node.
Dot.
JS is a javascript runtime engine built
on chrome's via javascript engine.
And what it does is it creates an event.
And here's the key.
Here's the key right here.
It creates an event driven nonblocking
I io model that makes it lightweight,
inefficient. Let's break this
down. I o means input output.
So this can be anything from
reading files, riding local files,
making an http request,
right?
Anything that you were inputting into a
model and then you're getting an output
that's an input output model.
But that,
but the problem with input output
models is the idea of blocking, right?
So blocking happens when you make a
request and there's another request.
But wait,
this request is not finished yet and now
it has to wait for the other request,
right? So it's blocked. Request
number two is blocked from,
from modifying, uh, the, the,
the APP because requests,
one is in process.
So what javascripts node dot js does is
it has this thing called the event loop.
Okay. And this is what the
event, Luke looks like.
The event loop consists of three different
modules. You have your call stack,
you have the node Api Apis and
you have your callback queue
and great two years for the audio.
Awesome. And also attention mechanisms.
I know you guys want attention mechanisms.
I need to make a dedicated video
about attention that's coming.
You can't just be like, oh this is a
tension but and then that's it. No,
attention is a is a
highly interesting topic.
It's an advanced topic and we will get
into that. I know you guys want it.
I want it to you know how much
I like attention mechanisms,
but basically the idea of attention
mechanisms is normally in a neural network
you have a bunch of things to choose from,
right?
The network has a bunch of options
on what to make a prediction width,
different submodules of data.
And what attention does is it says here
is the most important part of that data
to pay attention to and here's what
to make a prediction with. And it,
what it comes down to
is probabilities rights.
What's the percent likelihood that this
will result in an output that is most
aligned with the label that I have.
And there's different methods for this.
There's a whole field of study
dedicated to attention mechanisms.
You could dedicate a two,
three years to this. Okay,
so how does machine translation work?
And that was, that's a no dot js. Well,
before I get some machine translation,
let me just finish explaining no.
Dot js three modules here, the call
stack note APIs and the callback queue.
Okay. This is, this is very,
you know, trivial stuff. And
so here's an example, right?
So what happens is for these three
functions, well two functions,
what happens is they are first,
when you execute this code,
all of those functions
go onto the call stack.
The call sec then calls the node Api Apis,
right?
Set Timeout as a part of the node API.
And then both are both are place in the,
into the callback queue.
The callback queue is waiting for the call
stack to be empty and once it's empty,
it's going to send one by one, uh,
different functions to that call stack.
And then once and any new functions first,
enter the call stack,
call the node Api Apis,
then go to the callback queue and then
they're executed and the call stack again.
So it's kind of this loop,
right?
And so what happens is because
there's this process that's happening,
there's no blocking. And so what that
means is you can make concurrent requests,
not just one,
but a thousand requests at the same time.
And because there's
this loop functionality,
you don't have to wait for one request
to finish before starting the other one.
Now onto machine translation here is our
input data and our output data. Okay?
So what this is, let's look at
our data set. By the way. Uh,
our data set is an input output dataset.
Uh,
example LSTM sequence to
sequence a French data.
This is a very popular dataset
and there's a great tutorial for this
on the care Ross blog as well. Uh,
minds is going to be more interactive,
but let's see where the input data is.
Here it is. Okay. So that's
really what I want to.
And plus ours is going to be
in Javascript, not in python.
So this is our input data.
Okay. And they, this,
this website has a bunch of great
data sets for every language.
So a bunch of phrases like hello,
how are you with the associated, uh,
other language that has translated to,
I'm also going to be taking questions.
So in five minutes from now I'm
going to be taking questions,
so be sure to ask those questions
before I start coding. Okay.
So what we're going to do is we're going
to translate English to French. Okay.
So we downloaded an English French pair.
So the input looks like
this left column right here.
The output looks like this
right column right here.
And what we want to do is
learn that napping. Exactly.
We want to learn the
mapping between the two.
And so the first step for us
is to preprocess this data.
So what's it's going to look like is this,
it's going to be a set of word vectors
and here's what the first word vector
will look like. Go becomes
g o period. That's it.
And this is going to be an array where
every element in the array is a different
character. That's a part of that
phrase. And the output will be the same.
Great. Okay, so now, uh, for the
encoder decoder architecture,
here's how it works. We have
to recurrent networks. Okay.
We have a one recurrent network,
that's the, we call the end coder.
We have another recurrent neural network
neural network called the decoder.
So there's two neural networks here.
One acts as what's called the encoder.
And the other,
as a decoder,
the encoder is responsible for outputting
a fixed length in coding of the input
English sentence.
So recurrent networks are a type
of neural network that are fed,
not just the new, a new data point
in the next time step, right?
So feedforward networks are fed new
data points every time step, right?
So here's one data point.
Here's the next day to point.
Here's the next data point.
And every time step that that hidden
weight matrix that that is the neural
networks brain, essentially, it's
all of its learnings over time.
It's a collection of numbers,
right?
Ones and Zeros that gets better and better
through the optimization process for
normal feed forward neural
networks. You're just feeding
in input data and that,
uh, that, that, that weight matrix
for the network is kind of like Plato.
It's been cool. It's been molded over
time to be more and more optimized, right?
So it's be, it's becoming better and
better. So when you feed it a new output,
it's going to give you the perfect,
when you painted a new input,
it's going to give you the perfect output.
But recurrent networks are not
just vetting new input data.
So it's not just new data points. It's
also the, it's also the previous, um,
hidden state. So it's the previous
version of that Plato Weight Matrix.
So it's being fed both of those.
And the reason for that is because we're
current networks are made for learning
sequences. Now it does very well
with learning sequences, right?
So predicting the next character,
the next number, the next image,
the next frame in a sequence of images,
video,
it does very well at predicting sequences.
The problem is that there is a,
there is a problem with learning
long term memory, right?
So if forgets what happens in the past,
now I have some great
videos on LSTM networks.
This problem is called the vanishing
gradient problem and we can talk about it
forever, but basically Tldr, just
search LSTM Saroj for videos on that.
But,
uh,
the idea is that the gradient vanishes
slowly as we back propagate into previous
layers. And so there's a version
of the recurrent network. Um,
okay.
The version of the recurrent network
is called a n l s t m network. Okay.
So a long short term memory network.
And here's what it looks like.
And let's talk about this for a second
because it's very interesting in,
in addition to having a hidden state,
this LSTM recurrent network has a cell
state. And here's what a cell looks like.
Now, remember these words,
gates cells. These are just,
these are just ways for us to
understand what this actually is.
And what this actually is,
is a series of operations that
we are applying to input data.
And so we have what's
called an input gate. Uh,
forget gate and I'm an
output gate and a cell state.
We have four different things to be
thinking about here when we're thinking
about an LSTM cell.
And the whole idea behind this is to
trap that gradient over the long term.
And this kind of,
this,
this scheme has resulted in us being
able to trap that gradient in an earlier,
uh, layers of the network such that
it can remember longterm sequences.
So if you look at these gating
variables here, these three equations,
if we look at these three equations,
yeah.
All right. And I'm going to
answer questions right after this.
Let me just finish this.
If we look at these three equations,
we have an equation for the forget gate,
the input gate and the output Kate and
its input times weight add a bias and
then the parentheses activate. Remember,
input times weight, add a bias,
activate. These gates are just
single layer neural networks, right?
They are perceptrons where
we're taking the input,
multiplying it by its own
respective weight Matrix,
adding a bias value
and taking that output.
And what we do with all three of these
gates is we compute the cell state.
So look at this equation right here,
okay? What this equation is, is a, it is,
uh, when we are taking all of those gates
and we are, we're saying we're taking,
going to take the,
um,
okay,
the first equation,
multiply it by this cell state from the
previous time step plus the implicate
times his cell state.
And that gives us our cell state.
And then we take our output times tan
h the activation of the cell state.
And that gives us our hidden state.
So these two variables right here,
and this is our self safe
from the last time step.
These two variables right
here are what we care about.
And that's what the LSTM computes.
So when it comes to training,
here's how it works, okay?
So here is how it works.
Let me just say how it works and then
we're, we're, we're good with this. Okay?
So what's happening is we take,
okay,
so during the training phase,
we take our input sentence.
This is an English sentence,
okay?
We take that English sentence
and we feed it into the encoder.
So this is a vectorized version
of the English sentence.
We feed it to the first encoder,
the encoder, that's an LSTM network.
Now,
what we care about is not the output.
We care about the learn hidden state from
the encoder and what that hidden state
is, we can call it a lot of things. We
could call it a a Plato weight Matrix.
We can call it a, uh, we can call it a
okay,
a hidden state. We can call it, uh, uh, a
thought vector. We can call it a learning.
We can call it, uh, you know, it's what
it's learned. It's a dense representation.
It's a compressed version of
everything that it's learned over time,
a generalized version. And we use
that learned hidden state from the,
from the fruit,
from each iteration of the training
loop to initialize the decoder.
So that initial lot,
so that hidden state that's learned from
the encoder is used to initialize the
decoder. What the decoder is
fed is the French sentence.
So the English sentence, check this
out. You got to listen to this.
The English sentence is
given to the encoder,
the encoder output on a hidden state,
it will have an output.
But we don't care about that.
We only care about the hidden state.
Then it's learned. We feed the
hidden state to the decoder now too,
to initialize it and we feed the decoder
the French sentence. So what happened?
What's going to happen is the decoder is
going to translate the French sentence
using the learned hidden, say from
the encoder character by character.
It's going to predict every next
character given that input. Now, uh,
it's gonna output something that looks
very bad at first, but we have the label,
which is the actual French phrase.
We'll compare it via some lost function.
We'll use that to back, propagate
the gradient across both networks.
And we repeat until eventually
the output is going to be very,
very similar to the input, which is our
translated phrase. That's for training.
And then lastly, for inference, we're
going to encode the input sequence,
retrieved that state,
use it for the decoder,
and then we don't give it a French
phrase. We just immediately, uh,
output. We predict every next character
cause we don't have a label. Okay.
So now for questions, five questions
and I'll get to the code we have.
We have a lot of great code for use,
so don't even worry about that. Okay,
so question one,
uh,
how was it great for Linear Algebra?
Linear Algebra is the study of
Algebra apply to groups of numbers,
right? So normally you're multiplying
single numbers, four times five,
five times five,
and you're off,
you're applying operations
to single numbers.
But when you have groups of numbers,
matrices,
which are what neural networks
use that are run on Gpu,
that can do massive parallel computation,
you need a new type of math to be able
to apply operations to groups of numbers
at the same time. And that's why
linear Algebra, that's what it does.
And that's why it's important for
neural networks. Question two,
when is the school of the ice starting?
It's starting right now. A question three.
Oh and the next, the first course is
going to start in a few weeks. So, uh,
question three.
Hm.
What are the benefits of RNN
with Lstm over our end with Gru,
gru is actually, um, used more
often now, but I think lst,
m's are easier to understands. Um, lastly.
Okay.
Is He app similar to Google
translator? Yes. Well, I mean,
Google translate uses, um,
an encoder decoder architecture.
Uh,
it's very different than this one
now because it's iterated over time,
but it's essentially the same idea
of encoder and decoder architecture.
One more question.
Can you explain how data is formatted
and how it will be fed in? Yes.
Okay.
Data is going to be formatted
as an input vector, right?
Where every character is its own
element in that vector or a re, uh,
and then we're going to feed
that in. Okay. So now let's,
let's get into the code here.
Uh,
what do we got here? What time
are we at? Okay, cool. Cool,
cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
Uh, all right, so
cool. Um, so okay, where
do we begin here? So, uh,
if we go to node dot js, what we can do
is we can go to no job, no jazz stock,
or we can go to downloads.
And we could say what type of operating
system do we have? I have a Mac,
so I'll click on that and
that's going to install node,
the node dot js using a visual manager.
Okay.
It's a visual package manager. Once
we have that you, if you just joined,
you haven't missed the code part yet,
so that's the good part.
The code is going to be in the
video description by the way,
so definitely click on that. So inside
of node dot js, we can download this.
We can say it. Let's, let's,
let's look in the docs here. Well,
how do we get started with this,
right? No. Dot js looks hard. Well,
guides are usually the best place to look
in any kind of technical documentation
inside of the getting started guide.
Here's how we do it.
We create a simple sublime
file or a simple text file.
We paste this in and then we hit APP,
uh,
and we name an APP dot js and then
we in the command line type in node,
APP dot js and at local host 3000
we'll see the message. Hello world.
That's how you install node dot.
Js.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm going to get
right into the meat of this code that
we're going to use a, it's going to be
beautiful and we got to start somewhere.
So I'm going to write out this encoder
decoder architecture for ourselves, uh,
for us, and then we're going to start
coding it. Okay. So beautiful. So, um,
once we've installed tensorflow dot js,
so npm installed tentraflow dot
js uh, we can import it to, right?
So there's several ways to be
importing tensorflow. Dot. Js uh,
but what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to import it using NPM,
which is the node
package manager. Now, uh,
there's also another package
manager you should know about yarn,
which is just as good,
if not better than NPM,
that Facebook created because they
were having problems with npm. Okay.
And they tried everything really,
but they were still having problems.
And at the scale of Facebook,
of course you're going to have problems.
MMM.
Right? So now we're going to
load the pretrained models.
So this a class file will contain the
pretrained model for us that we can use
later on. Uh, what else
are we going to import?
We also have some basic dom elements
that I've written out in a separate file
that we're going to look at, but
that's really, it tends to dot.
JS is like our main file here.
And then we're going to talk
about the other things. Okay.
So now let's load our
pretrained models as well.
So we're going to have some
pretrained models. Uh, we're
still gonna build models,
but I just want to load them so we
have both options, right? So we could,
we could load our pretrained
models or, uh, we can just,
okay, cool. I just wanted to see
what people are saying. We can, uh,
download pretrained models or we can
have it from the web or
downloaded from the web.
So I'm going to download it from
the web. I think it's, where's the,
okay,
what were these,
uh,
API APIs called? What was this
website called? Oh, here we go.
Okay.
That's what it was called. So
these are the, this is the,
so Google has this pretrained model
on the web for us as a Jason File.
So these models are saved as Jason files,
but it's not just the model.
There's also metadata, right? So
metadata includes things like versioning,
information, timestamps,
um, things like that.
Everything that's around the model, but
it's not necessarily the model. Okay?
So we're going to initialize
this as a constant file.
These are hosted model URLs,
so we can load pretrained models
will also build the model.
So don't even worry about it.
Okay, so we've got that. Great.
Now we have our train model.
We have our hosted URLs.
Now we can, um, create
our translator class.
So not now let's build a translator.
Okay, so here's how we do this.
We define a class called translator.
Inside of the translator class.
We're going to initialize it and we're
going to use the ASYNC function because
we don't want to wait for
the dom elements to load.
When we initialize our class file.
Now we're going to initialize it
using the URLs that we are provided.
We will build our own models for sure.
Now I'm going to initialize that
URLs file as it as our own variable.
I'm going to say,
well here's our model and we're going
to wait for it to load using the await
function. And I haven't going
to have a function for low load,
the hosted pretrained model
using the URLs dot models.
Okay. And we have that. Okay,
so that is our model right there.
What it does,
the await function by the way, it just
expresses it. That expression just,
it causes the async function to uh,
the,
to pause until this function that,
that it's a weighting has, has loaded.
So that's why we did that.
Now we're going to do the same thing
using the away to method for uh,
the Metadata, right? We cause
we have metadata as well.
It's not just the model itself.
We have the metadata and this model
actually consists of two parts.
We have our,
remember we have our encoder,
so we're going to call it prepare
in coder model and it has rd coder.
And in these functions that
I'm defining right here,
we're going to segment out this
model and then prepare both of them.
And I'll return this at the very end.
That's our initialization
function for our translator class.
Okay, so, um, let's start off with the,
the metadata because right, it's not
just the model that we're loading.
It's the metadata as well.
We have two different things to
be loading here. Let me also see.
Hi everybody. Okay. I just want to
see what everybody's saying. Cool,
cool. We have people joining
it and we have people leaving.
Don't leave. Stay, stay.
Okay.
This is important stuff.
This is more important than web
development in general. Look,
machine learning is the
future of all code. Okay?
Everything's going to be machine learning
and if you want to stay on top of
things, you need to understand how this
works. Starting with metadata. Okay,
so back to metadata.
Back to metadata.
Where were we?
So we can retrieve this
metadata from our helper class.
Cause we have a helper class here
and we're going to use
the loader for member.
I imported that loader
at the very beginning
load hosted metta data using the URLs.
Metadata.
Okay, so that's the loader.
That's our translation. Meta data.
Now we can say, well,
let's take our decoder.
Okay.
And so one of the, so now we're going
to retrieve something from the metadata.
So we're, remember we were
treating what already exists,
so we can say what we know that one
of the variables of the Metadata,
and if we look into tensorflow, docs,
this has these, it has these features,
but one of the variables of the input
data or of the metadata is the Max
sequence length for both
the encoder and the decoder.
Okay,
let me zoom out a bit so people can see
what we're talking about here or there
we go. Now we have the
same thing for our encoder.
So we have a Max decoder length.
We have a max in Kotor length.
And again,
we can use that same
model to retrieve that.
And it's going to look very similar except
it's going to be called the encoder.
Yes.
Yeah,
you're right.
Cool.
Uh,
Max encoder sequence length,
right. Okay. Yes. So now we
have our Dakota or we ever
encoder sequenced length.
And now, uh, there's,
there's actually, um,
cool
cons. Yes. So cons needs to be,
let's see. Translation, metadata.
Oh, rivalry. Thanks. Um, right.
There we go. Thank you.
Right? Yes, thank you guys.
This is how we do it. Crowd sourced
debugging. So now back to this.
So we have our,
we have a token index as well.
Now the reason we're going to use this
token index is so we have a way of
knowing where in the phrase we are,
when we are predicting the
next character in the sequence,
we need a way to predict where we are.
And so the metadata has
that and it's called the,
it's called the input to token index.
Now we have that not just for the input,
but we have this for the target index.
Now what the target index is,
is it's the final label that
we are trying to predict,
right?
So that label is the output French phrase.
Okay? So that's our index. No,
that's it for metadata.
Now I want to prepare the encoder model.
Prepare encoder model.
Okay?
And it's going to take
the model as its input.
So it's going to segment out the
encoder model using the, the, the,
the pretrained weights. And
we can, we can do is we can,
we can train it on our own data, right?
So it's already been trained on uh,
you know, language pairs, but
we can just train it ourselves.
We can just add training to it.
Right?
And also this is the future of machine
learning where you don't necessarily have
to train your own model from scratch
every time because someone else has done
that in the same way that you
don't have to write code, right?
You don't have to write all the bare
bones code for everything every time
someone has already done that.
So you import a library.
So the paradigm that we're going to
start seeing with machine learning is one
where we are not just importing libraries,
we are importing pretrained
models and not just single models,
but multiple models trained on
multiple different types of data.
And we can combine all of these models
together and then train it on our own
data and we won't need as
much data because of it.
It's a much more efficient process.
Now enough of that. And let's
get back to this. Okay. So, uh,
back to the encoder model.
So what does this look like?
So how many encoder Toki
encoder token count,
how many encoder tokens do we have?
Right? So what these tokens are,
are the number of characters that
we are inputting into the encoder.
And what we can do is we get,
yeah,
for the length of this,
and it's going to be of size of shape too
because there are three different, um,
zero one, two. So those are the elements
in the array. There are three different,
uh, words in a phrase and
we can say that's well,
that's going to be the number of tokens.
Now we have to decide,
well how many inputs
is going to be in this?
And we can use the equal sign.
We could say,
well modeled on input zero.
That's going to be the,
that's going to be input to the model.
Now remember,
we are using the hidden
states as the, as the, uh,
initial app as the medium with
which to initialize a decoder.
So,
so we need to retrieve both of those.
So we have our hidden state, state H,
which we're going to retrieve from the
models. And we're going to say, well,
here's a specific layer
where it's out where it's at,
but it's not enough to just, uh,
it's not enough to just say, we,
we need the hidden state.
We also need to have that cell state.
So remember,
recall I just talked about LSTM networks.
And what LSTM networks do
is they don't just have a,
they don't just offer a hidden states.
They offer cell states.
That's what's learned.
And what does that prevent that prevents
the vantage and gradient problem.
And what does that do? That lets
us learn longterm sequences. Okay?
So that's our hidden state.
That's our cell state.
And what we can do is we can say,
well,
let's create a new list and put those
values into this single list that we've
just defined.
And we'll take that list and we'll
use it to build the model. Okay,
I see it. Translation, Metadata,
uh,
input token index.
It is right.
Translation metadata.
Okay.
Yes, I will use a semi colon consistently.
We got some, we got some Java script. Um,
people in here, which is good.
It's not just all python people.
We want diversity. We want
variety guys. Okay. Javascript,
python, look, python is what is obviously
where it's at for machine learning.
And this is kind of controversial to say,
but if I were to pick a number
two language for machine learning,
I'm going to pick javascript,
not are not scholar, not go, not,
not, uh, Matlab for sure. Um,
but it's javascript. Um, and
there's a lot of reasons for that,
but there's a lot of developer activity
around javascript libraries for machine
learning and have a great video on that
coming out this weekend, by the way. So,
um, now we can build the model. So now
we're actually using a tentraflow dot.
Js function,
TF dot model to build this thing.
And, um, we can say, well,
here are our inputs and here our outputs
are outputs are going to be the states,
right? Because we want
those states to be fed into
the
decoder.
So that's what we're out putting.
Okay?
Okay. So that's us preparing our encoder
and now let's prepare the decoder.
Prepare.
Okay.
Prepare decoder model using the same.
Remember we are segmenting out this model.
Oh, I see, I see.
You're right. Yes, that's what you meant.
Okay. I just want to fix some syntax
here and now we're back. Thank you.
So prepared. Decoder model
looks like this. So again,
we are going to do the same kind of
basic idea where we are deciding what we
are.
We are trying to see what the number of
a decoder tokens are going to be.
So they nom decoder tokens and it's
gonna be modeled on input one that shape.
And then we're going to say, well,
okay, so let's define our hidden state.
So we have, our constants
are hidden state, uh,
and that hidden state is going to be just
that. Again, we have our hidden state.
Uh, now what we need to do
is define a latent dimension.
Now the reason we are defining this
lightened dimension using the hidden state
is it's going to help us define
the input. Now let me talk about
what exactly I mean by that.
So it's going to be one less than
the hidden states size or length.
Because
how many live people
do we have by the way?
Constantly in dementia. Cool.
Cool. All right. So, um,
so we're gonna use this latent dimension
to help us define the inputs directly
into both hidden states.
So let me show you what I mean.
So I have a decoder state input.
H
I have a decoder,
state
input C,
which is the cell states.
And then I have a decoder
state inputs variable. Okay.
So these are our three variables
equal sign up 54. Thank
you. Okay, thank you.
All right. Um, now, now,
now we're going to actually use some
tensorflow. Dot. JS input functions.
One is going to be t f. Dot. Input
shape using the latent dimension.
Here is why we use the
lightened dimension.
We are using the shape of the hidden
state minus one to define the decoder
states hidden state.
Okay.
So it's going to be minus one because we
are predicting the next character in a
sequence, right? It's not the,
it's it's going to be the, if,
if the input sequences t we're
predicting t plus one. So the next one.
So the input shape has to start one
before [inaudible] 67 thank you.
Latent dimension is the
shape we have our name,
which is going to be decoder state in
cooked h k and now let's do the same
thing. Let's make this a little
smaller so we can all see this.
Let's do the same thing for
the cell state and we'll do the same
thing. Now these are our inputs.
Now that we've defined both of them,
now we can say, well, here's our
input age and here's our inputs.
See,
now these are our state inputs,
right?
So these are our hidden states
and these are our, these are our,
this is our hidden states
and ourselves state. Okay,
now that we have both of them,
now let's retrieve the l s t m model.
Just like that.
Okay, so I just want to
take a little break to say,
Quan Luis Clore said,
how do you convince the public we really
live in the machine learning era? Well,
it's too hard for a country like Bolivia
and suit America believe to believe in
that.
I don't care where you live.
You can live in Antarctica as long as
you have an internet connection and some
kind of computing devices,
it can be a hundred dollar convert to
your local currency Chromebook as long as
you can access.
Let me show you this.
Co lab.research.google.com.
Okay?
You go to this in your browser, okay?
This could even be Internet explorer,
like the worst browser ever,
but as long as you have a browser,
you create a notebook.
You say hello world in that notebook,
you hit this.
It's compiling it on an Nvidia k,
80 GPU. You have 12 hours of
training time on this thing for free.
It compiled it on that. Any printed
it out? You have everything.
You have your algorithms. Okay? That's
all available. Um, machine learning,
sub reddit. It's available on the
tutorials online. You have the data.
It's all available using awesome. Get
held public lists. Um, Reddit r slash.
Datasets. You have the
education, me, other youtubers.
You have the compute here. So I don't
want to hear, I live in South America,
Bolivia, whatever. I can't do machine
learning. I don't care where you are here,
you can do this. So don't ever, uh, give
me an excuse like that again. All right,
so that's, that's enough of that. Um,
I, he will be suing me. No, no, no.
Actually Microsoft asked me to
make an a zero video and I said no.
So let's see them. Sue me again. All
right, so here we go. Back to this.
Where was I? I got a little off track.
A little passionate about that one.
Thank you.
Back to the,
what about variable name?
Right, right, right, right.
Thank you. Okay, so online 70.
Okay.
We have our TF dot input.
Um, what, what went on here?
Yeah.
Interesting.
Looks fine to me. T F. Dot. Input Age.
Okay, so back to the retrieving the
LSTM models. So we can say, well,
here's our decoder and we already have,
um,
our decoder,
uh,
we're going to take that last
layer of the decoder decoder.
Lstm
good capital l.
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Capital l there is no Capitol Hill.
Okay.
So back to this,
we're going to define our initial input
by saying all those layers going through
their Dakota LSTM um
oh, capital items instead of Oh, I
see, I see, I see, I see. So again,
thank you capitol. I, here we go. Ah,
Gotcha.
Got It.
Cool.
All right, cool. So now inputting
book Capitol Capitol. Great,
please zoom guys. How much zooming
do you want here? Okay, here we go.
The current state of LCM inputs.
Zero. So this is our initial input.
Okay.
This is our initial input and now we
can initialize the model using the first
input and the hidden states input,
which we've already defined here.
So we can say apply outputs
equals decoder.
Lstm
how much time has passed so far?
Do you coach? Thanks. No, I mean
like how long has this streaming
decoder inputs
state state. Cool, thanks.
All right,
that's our outputs.
All right. I have about 10 more lines
of code here. Ah, so stick around.
I have 10 more lines of code and I'm
going to answer some questions at the very
end. Okay. I'm going to
answer some questions.
So don't go anywhere back to
this decoder states inputs.
Right?
So now I have those outputs.
MMM.
So what we want to do is we
want to get that last output.
It hasn't been activated yet.
We haven't applied a dense
fully connected layer to it.
So we have both of our hidden states, by
the way, we have both of them already,
both the hidden states
and the cell states.
And what we can do is we can just say,
let's take the first element
of this apply outputs.
Okay.
Array or list and store that
in the decoders hidden states.
And we'll do the same
thing for the cell state.
And that's just going to be the next, the
next one. And then we have our hidden,
so these hidden states,
we're going to get their own list.
Now that we finally retrieved
these hidden states, we can,
we can give them their own list.
And so
these alone aren't going to do anything.
We have to apply a fully
connected layer to them.
What this is going to do is it's
going to output a probability value.
Why do we want a probability value?
That's what the dense layer is,
because a probability value will allow us
a probability value will allow us
to make a prediction on what character
is the most probable next character.
Right? So if it's going to say
you know, 70%, um, you know,
h and it's very likely going
to be h as the next character.
And that's what we apply a dense layer
to to it. So to get that final outputs,
we're gonna use that dense layer
two.
MMM.
To define that output.
We have our decoder model or so
that's our, that's our final output.
We applied the dense layer to the
outputs. Now we have a prediction. Okay.
So the decoder model
is going to use,
it's its own TF model.
Okay.
And it's going to use as input to the
decoders inputs concatenated with the
states,
the state inputs,
outputs.
Thank you.
And we have our outputs,
which are the decoder outputs.
Okay.
That's it for this little
portion of code gets,
okay, let's review what I've written
here, by the way. Okay, let's review this.
So
my 97 right there we go.
Making sure I got all my,
I still haven't registered sublime text
at this point. It's just become a meme.
Like I will never register a
sublime text because I just,
I dunno why sublime better like sponsor
me or something. I don't care now.
I don't worry about it. I
love you sublime. I don't know
why. I just don't want to,
I like being a rebel back to this.
MMM.
I, my friend Hawes Balaban Ian
who is helping me live stream.
That's you sitting next to me. So He's
helping me with this live stream stuff.
Okay. He's got to be our
channel back to this. Uh,
okay. So let's just, let's just go.
Anybody can go to TF js
examples and here's your,
are all of these examples, by the way,
you have your card poll. All right.
This balances a car pull in the
browser and it's got a live demo.
Most of them have live demos in
the browser that you can see.
If you just click see the example live,
I want you to for sure go to this, uh,
get hub repository. If you haven't yet
looked at, think training in the browser.
Okay?
Okay. And so are, so what I'm gonna do,
I'm going to download this right now.
I mean, download it. Let me
click open. Let me go to it.
Okay.
Terminal. Let me go into
it. Make this bigger.
And now let's run this ourselves.
So CD translation,
and then I'm going to answer
some questions right after
I run this demo. Okay?
So if we go here, let's, let's look at
this. What does it say? Translation. Okay.
It says to do two things. Yarn and
yarn. Watch. So yarn, I can do that.
So what yarn is, is it's a version of
NPM that Facebook created. Remember,
uh,
that that can,
that bypasses a lot of the
issues with NPM at scale.
And so once we've run yarn,
now we can run yarn watch.
And what yarn watch is going to do
is in the browser at our local host,
it's going to run that pretrained model.
Okay? At local host,
one, two, three, four.
Now it's going to show up here,
okay?
That's the whole point is
that it needs to show up.
Now we're going to load that pretrained
model and we're going to go ahead and
say you are cool.
Do [inaudible] that's my French,
right? They're homeless. Do flow,
mush, homeless dude format.
Okay. Question Time.
So just ask questions.
I'm reading all of this in real time.
Let's answer some questions here.
Yeah.
Uh, linked to everything is going
to be in the video description.
Definitely check out colab that
research.google.com check out the get hub
repository for tenths
below dot. Js. I love you.
The school of AI first course
will start in a few weeks.
I have big things planned for everybody.
It's a very exciting time right now.
And uh, yarn does not
come with Hadoop. However,
you can use yarn with Hadoop.
Why use a different activation function
h in one place? That's a great question.
So, uh, check out my video. Which
activation function should I use?
Saroj just Google that.
Any advantage of no dot
js over Python r um, yes.
One example is the ability to
easily use distributed computing,
right?
So client side machine learning involves
using the gps of whoever the host is.
And if we use client side
machine learning with Javascript,
you can train it on their
gps in real time. Now,
you could do this with python
using Django and flask,
but it's much easier with javascript.
Okay,
three more questions.
Uh,
how can I make a related
word to a specific topic? Ai.
Okay. Word two, Vec Ghoul that
word or no? Youtube that word.
Two VEC Suraj.
But you turn words into vectors and then
you can find a similarity between these
vectors. It's a numerical operation
and we're, Yvonne says, I'm the cutest.
I'm sure and passionate says deep
learning with Django. It's not a question.
Last question. Okay. The
last question is the shawl.
The shawl asks,
can you suggest some good books for
linear Algebra with regard to machine
learning? No, I'm not gonna. I'm
not gonna suggest good books. Why?
Because you can very easily learn
linear Algebra from three blue,
one brown. Okay? If you
search linear Algebra,
my buddy grant here, promoting them
right now, essence of linear Algebra,
definitely check out this series.
Amazing playlist.
This is enough. Watch all of this.
Then watch math of intelligence by me.
If I do say so myself on amazing playlist.
Okay.
This is when I was in Europe.
I was just like going through that.
I was just so hype. You know what I'm
saying? Like I was totally in the zone.
I was combining art and music and like
everything together with machine learning,
it was sick.
Now I have to outdo that with my first
school of Ai Ai course and I will.
But that, that's, that's that
question. Okay. So anyway.
Okay,
I love you too. Look, you guys don't
need to qualify. I'm not gay. Okay.
Even if you are gay, that's fine.
Who Cares? Okay. People are gay.
That's humans.
But I love you too.
It's okay for us to be able to say I
love you as men, as women, whatever.
Okay. We are beyond gender roles by
the way. We are you guys, listen,
we are moving beyond being a human.
We're moving beyond these bodies,
period. So forget about gender roles.
We are merging into this super
intelligent civilization using Ai.
So don't even trip about like, I'm
not gay. I love you by the way.
And lastly, um, will it be free?
Of course it's going to be free.
Yes, it's going to be free.
And I have so much content
coming out for you this weekend.
It's going to blow your mind. We are
living in such an exciting time right now.
Next week we're going to have our
first school of Ai meetups starting.
I'm going to contact all the people
who I've selected to be deans.
It's going to be amazing.
You guys are amazing.
This is the most important
community in the world.
Nobody as the community globally is
doing as much in terms of impact.
And you know why? Because nobody's
using AI as much as we are.
We are the most AI aware, active,
hungry, ambitious community in the world.
And it's all thanks to you guys.
All right, so that's it for this.
I'm not going to rap because it's kind
of laggy right now, but I will wrap,
I promise you in the next livestream.
Okay? So lots of reps are coming.
I love you guys and thanks for watching.